(upbeat music)
- [Thoraya] I think you
have a beautiful smile,
first of all.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
- [Thoraya] Are you
confident in your smile?
- Hmm.
Yeah, I'm pretty confident in my smile.
- I think it's the thing that disarms
the people the most, with me.
So I'm very confident in my smile.
I think that the thing that
I'm absolutely best at,
in the entire world,
better than anybody else
is making eye contact with somebody
and then smiling at them
and acknowledging their presence.
So, yeah, I like my smile.
- How does the state of my
smile impact how I feel?
So I will say I am more
inclined to smile, very big,
when I have just brushed my teeth.
- I mean, I feel like this is
kind of a materialistic answer,
but I'd say that like when
it's been a whole long day
and I haven't brushed my
teeth since the morning,
I definitely don't feel as confident
as like when I have freshly brushed teeth.
- I didn't realize how much
a smile could really convey
because I never smiled in photos.
I was always like scowling
or brooding looking,
and I just thought I had an ugly smile.
I thought I had too many,
my teeth were small.
I thought I had gaps in my teeth.
Then I just became more
comfortable and realizing like,
this is the only smile I got.
So I'm just gonna try and
use it as much as I can.
- [Thoraya] What do you think
is the number one chronic
disease in America?
- Number one chronic disease,
depression.
- Probably mental health.
- In America or the world?
- [Thoraya] America.
- America, obesity.
- Probably cardiovascular
disease, I would say.
- I think that the major chronic
illness is heart disease.
- [Thoraya] It's a good guess.
It's actually tooth decay.
- Wow.
Okay, did not see that one coming.
- Way off, I was way off, way off.
- Tooth decay?
Oh.
- [Thoraya] Is that
shocking at all, to hear?
- That's very shocking.
It's definitely a reality
that people don't realize
and probably overlook that
having access to good, proper
dental care, is a privilege.
And we are very lucky.
Those of us that are able
to just have things like
toothpaste and toothbrushes and mouthwash
and everything else at our disposal.
- I mean, man, if you think about it,
teeth are actually decaying
inside of your mouth.
That's a disease for sure.
People don't think about it
because I guess it's so
prevalent and nobody really,
like, I can't say nobody cares,
but like, I don't know,
just lack of awareness.
And, you know, when you
say the word ignorant,
it's not in any derogative sense
because I am very ignorant.
I don't know how to
change my oil by myself.
I'm ignorant on how to do so.
So ignorance is the main reason
why people don't know that tooth decay
is the most prevalent disease.
- I think there's probably less access
to affordable dental care.
Primary care comes first,
but I think dental care is
probably an afterthought
for a lot of people.
And I never went to the dentist as a child
because just in my family, you know,
we didn't have a lot of money,
so it was never a priority.
You know, we didn't have a lot of money,
but we were broke.
So if that was the case for me,
I can only imagine what
it's like for other families
that also didn't have that bandwidth.
Yeah, it's something that I hope
that becomes more accessible
to more people as time goes on.
- Maybe people are prioritizing things
more than dental care.
If they only have like access
to a certain amount of resources.
Maybe they are putting other things first
'cause they think that
that's more important
or they're maybe like putting it off.
That's what I would think.
- Hey, everyone Thoraya here.
I think, and I'm sure we could all agree
that all smiles are beautiful,
but it's about how we personally feel
about our smile and that matters most.
And I'm not just talking about how we feel
about our smile visually,
but also the health of
our smile and oral health.
Tooth decay is the number one
chronic disease in America.
And no one is immune.
Every American deserves a healthy smile,
but Crest and Oral B know that
the opportunities to achieve
it, aren't always equal.
This year Crest and Oral B are on mission
to make great oral health a reality
for everyone in America.
And now I want you all to come with me
on a journey where we
will get to see firsthand
how Crest and Oral B are
helping make a positive change
by providing equitable
access to dental care,
education and products.
(hands clap)
- Let's go.
(upbeat music)
- I think you should start with my story.
And that leads into what I do.
I grew up in a low-income household
and I had amazing parents who care for me,
but unfortunately they
didn't know about oral health
or the importance of prevention.
Nobody ever taught them or
educated them about those things.
And so then in turn,
they didn't educate me.
I didn't know that I should be brushing
or that I should be flossing
or about nutritional counseling.
That I shouldn't eat all the candies.
And so, as a consequence, I
had a lot of dental problems,
but because I was low income,
I didn't have access to dental care.
(upbeat music continues)
The first time I went to a dentist,
I was probably around 13 years old.
I was in such extreme pain,
that I couldn't sleep.
This pain wouldn't go away.
And my mom took me to a dentist.
That dentist told my mom
that I needed a root canal
and my parents couldn't afford that.
So instead my mom took me
home and she ground up cloves.
She would mix it with water
and I would stick it into
the hole in my tooth.
And then I would try
to sleep away the pain.
And while the home remedies helped some,
it didn't help completely.
So I just suffered through it.
That memory is very vivid for me.
I remember the sun being bright.
I remember the green and yellow sheets.
I know that I was laying at an angle,
is a very vivid memory for me.
I'm pretty sure I had some
sort of periotreatment
because I remember as a young girl,
I would wake up in the morning
and there'd be blood on my pillow
and there'd be dried blood
on the corners of my mouth
and my mouth would be sick.
But that stopped happening
after I received my dental care.
And I made that connection.
Since then, I've become
a dental hygienist.
The first one in my family
to graduate from college.
And I chose dental hygiene.
I've organized around 40
community outreach events,
and these events are
free to the community.
We do free oral cancer screenings,
free instruments, education,
because I truly believe
in the power of education
in offering people resources
and letting them know the
resources available to them.
- [Thoraya] So how has
it been working with
Crest and Oral B?
How did you start working with them?
- Yeah, Crest and Oral B's been amazing
through my story of access to care.
They've supported me and
in my entire journey,
in my vocal Latinidad,
they've supported me in being a minority
and being strong and outspoken,
and I love that.
But it's really made an
impact in my community.
They've provided me with free products
to give to my patients.
Things that I otherwise in our clinic
doesn't have resources
to sometimes purchase.
And so through them, not
only are they supplying us
with things which might seem
minimal for our patients
who don't have resources,
who don't have money,
it makes an impact for them.
Because otherwise they wouldn't
have access to these things.
We ask the children, if
they have a toothbrush
before we ask them if they're brushing,
because a lot of children
don't have toothbrushes.
I didn't have a toothbrush growing up.
You know, there was
probably things around,
but nothing doesn't mean to me.
And we've learned that in our communities,
it's so easy to assume that everybody
has the same resources that we do.
And that's not the reality.
Maybe it's our reality,
but it's not the reality for the majority
of the United States.
We talk about cavities being
the number one chronic disease.
What does that tell you?
That tells you that there's
a disparities happening.
And that's not just me and my experiences
there are statistics and
studies that show that.
You mentioned earlier, like
when was the last time your cheeks hurt?
My cheeks hurt right now,
just talking about Crest and Oral B,
because I am really appreciative to them.
And the support that
they've given not just me,
but my patients, and, you
know, as a big company,
like Crest and Oral they
don't have to do those things.
And yet they do.
And I don't see any other company
out there doing those things.
Yeah, they took an interest in me and I,
and I don't necessarily feel like I bring
that much value to them.
But they definitely bring
value to me and to my patients.
I didn't want to cry.
They choose to highlight
communities that are suffering,
communities that do need advocacy,
communities that are often overlooked.
That's says a lot to me.
I think when we think about dental care
and how we take it for granted
and we're dealing with these children
and we think that their
lives are so simple.
Their lives aren't simple,
their lives are complicated.
We want to provide them with
education and resources.
We're there to help them.
And if we're not there to help them,
then we don't need to be there.
And I truly believe that.
I am not their savior.
We are not their savior.
What we're doing is important,
but it's one thing that we're doing.
And so if we're not there to do the good,
then we shouldn't be there.
And I think that we are.
I don't know.
I just, I keep thinking back on how,
I kind of imagined this for myself,
being that child who was
laying in a bed, in pain,
unable to sleep,
and now to be partnering
with Crest and Oral B,
to bring access to care,
to children like me,
to people like my parents,
like my grandparents,
what a better life.
And I'm truly grateful
that Crest and Oral B
that they are supporting me in my mission
in caring for the community
in turning a little girl's
suffering into a mission
so that other children don't have
to suffer these same things.
(upbeat music continues)